foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual real amazing relationships the
phone number here is triple eight eight
two five five two two five number one
best-selling author Ramsay personality
and host of the Ken Coleman show is my
co-host today which means we've got the
career expert jobs expert in the house
we'll be talking about that and with you
as we go throughout the show today
thanks for joining us again triple eight
eight two five five two two five Tony
starts this hour in Detroit hey Tony
what's up
hey how you doing better than I deserve
man how can I help good deal I have a
quick question for you we I have a
number of rentals
um one of the rentals has a mortgage on
it and me and my wife can't agree on if
we should keep it or sell it I would
like to sell it she would like to keep
it
okay the other the other rentals don't
have a mortgage
uh correct okay so this is the only debt
you have how about your personal
residence
uh has a mortgage as well okay you have
any other debt
um yeah I guess I do have a a truck that
has a law on it mm-hmm
so what do you why why are you want to
sell this property
um so I mean my my job and I just don't
want to focus on the ups and downs of
rental this one right now is an Airbnb
and
um yeah I just am I'm over the so I'm
overthinking about it
so the hassle
correct and she doesn't want to sell it
why she doesn't want to sell because it
it does it would make a decent amount of
money if we could pay it off quickly it
would you know bring in about 20. that's
assuming she continues to have free
labor from you
very true
yeah if we have to hire management if we
have to hire a management firm to run
this freaking nightmare called an Airbnb
then suddenly your margins are going to
go to squat
can run it for about three thousand a
month and then less insurance and uh and
taxes
I just said you had to hire somebody
else to manage it
yeah
yeah if you keep it you have to do that
because you're done correct
yeah how much do you make on it if you
sell it
um we would make about well we'd profit
about a hundred
okay
well I think that I think the core issue
is is that you guys are not on the same
page on where you want to end up
if you decide on where we want to end up
where do we want to be in five years and
do we want to be king and queen of the
airbnbs
um and uh being dead on my truck and uh
being dead on our house and uh be
spending too much time bunch of time on
this this is what we want our life to be
five years from now
um if it is then you probably should
keep it
but if you have a different set of uh
uh if you agree on a different set of
targets that you're going after I want
to be debt free with my stupid truck
paid off I'm gonna pay off our house and
I'm gonna get out of the Airbnb hassle
business and have a calm peaceful life
again
um if that's your goal then obviously
you'd sell it so you know if you were
working the Ramsay plan you'd sell it
but you're not working the Ramsey plant
you're just arguing with your wife
about whether to sell a rental
you're just you know that's all that's
going on so you know you're just doing
whatever the flip you want to do and
y'all are arguing about this one thing
so but that but the reason you're having
this disagreement is you you're not in
agreement on your long-term goals and
when you get an agreement on your
strategic long-term goals then the
Tactical miscellaneous steps to get
there will fall right in line and you'll
be agreement on those yeah and I think
you make a very good point about the
long-term goals I'm not sure that
they're both truly looking at long term
not they're looking at just this one
thing yeah she's like well they have
other rentals and they're not thinking
about well if we sell the house we make
a hundred we pay off the truck we've got
these other properties that are cash
flowing they got to think 20 30 years
down the line I think that's the great
advice you're giving there and then once
we can get on the same page about our
desired future then it's a lot easier
decision there's nothing really to argue
about if we have a long-term Vision that
we agree on exactly exactly Evan is with
us in Denver Colorado hi Evan how are
you
good David
better than I deserve how can we help
yeah I see a lot of people are turning
towards artificial intelligence and Robo
advisors to get their financial advice
I was curious to see what you thought
about that is that a good thing or a bad
thing I know from what I played around
with it they don't necessarily say your
advice is bad but they don't disagree
with it or agree with it
um I know particularly they say there is
such thing as good debt and that uh the
best way to get out of debt is a debt
Avalanche
well I mean you just got to decide who
you want to be advising you chat bot or
human
[Music]
I just I see a lot of financial advisors
putting it into their practices I was
just wondering is it a dangerous thing
is it a good thing yeah it's both Ai and
Robo investing is is good it's there's
nothing wrong with any of it
um especially where you're dealing with
a very small account and you're just
getting started and it causes you at a
low cost to get started as an investor
but if I was managing a million dollars
am I letting a chat bot do that no no
don't think so
yeah really I mean AI stuff's very
impressive
um we were I was looking at a meeting
this morning some of the stuff that
we're going to be able to do with it
it's uh it's ridiculous yeah uh how how
cool some of this stuff is but with it
comes the danger of no human oversight
and um and that's the the only way you
know if the advice coming out of it is
accurate is you're measuring it against
a human's value system that's the point
and Evan I would tell you that
artificial intelligence is about
knowledge what it lacks is wisdom and
that's what Dave's talking about you're
talking about a guide a human being who
understands principles through
experience and AI is nothing more than a
world-class aggregation tool if you want
to just break it down and so it's
knowledge knowledge knowledge but the
answer to your question lies in what you
said artificial intelligence it's not
wisdom it's knowledge that has been
aggregated and you need wisdom and it's
never going to replace the human touch
so here's the thing
you are always in charge of your money
not your financial advisor whether it's
AI whether it's Robo whether it's an
individual human being you have to
understand where the money's going you
are in charge of it it's your fault if
it screws up because you let it happen
it's your money and so you know it and
so what that means is if your financial
advisor says oh there's good debt you
need to go borrow on your house you go
huh I need a new financial advisor this
one's an idiot
oh you know you need to go get a
universal life policy oh I need a new
financial advisor this one's an idiot
and so you know you you have to make
those calls because you've already
decided certain things you're going to
do and not going to do and regardless of
who it is that's coming at you whether
it's
which kind of to me it's very
interesting it's almost an oxymoron to
say artificial intelligence it's like
you know like Airlines service you know
these things don't go in the same
sentence but anyway the uh but but it is
very impressive and it is a great
aggregator so it's going to be kind of
fun to see what kind of what we can do
with it as a tool uh but is it am I
going to turn my life over to a single
human a robo advisor or an AI chat bot
not a chance I'm in charge of my life my
job to manage it I can listen to what
they have to say and decide if I want to
fire them or not this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsay today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America I'm
Dave Ramsey your host Ken Coleman Ramsay
personality number one best-selling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
is my co-host today now this is fun we
got big news this is something we have
never done in the history of Ramsay in
30 years
well with the exception when I used to
teach Financial Peace University with an
overhead projector and a bad suit but
ever since the class has been Global and
is being taught in tens of thousands of
locations at any given time all over
America we've never done this for the
first time ever our team of Ramsay
personalities are each going to lead
a Financial Peace University class
online is true Ken Coleman is going to
be your coordinator that's Jade warshaw
is going to be your coordinator of your
class and you're going to be in
discussions with them you're going to be
held accountable by them in the group if
you get in the group now these groups
are limited because the technology is
limited on how many people we can put in
there so
again Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz can you
imagine being in Dr John deloney's
Financial Peace University class I would
put your seatbelt on that would
absolutely yeah George camel Jade
warshaw these are great oh yeah and
Eddie Eddie Cohen our event host is
gonna he's gonna he's gonna lead a class
oh yeah each of them are going to have
their own class that means you're going
to go through if you sign up quick
enough to get in their class it means
they're going to take Financial Peace
University you get to pick who you want
to guide you through it good you got to
go sign up starting right now you gotta
buy get in the class and pick which one
of these guys you want to do this is a
big deal this is your chance to learn
how to handle your money from an actual
Ramsay personality being your
coordinator now they're going to be
right there for you during the zoom
meetings you can talk to them face to
face these classes are starting very
soon and they're going to fill up in
about two seconds again there's not a
lot of spots because we can only put so
many people in a class with the zoom
technology and all that stuff so sign up
right now by going to Financial Peace
Universe Ramsey Solutions uh oh I'm
sorry fpu.com you go to
fpu.com of course you can go to Ramsay
Solutions and click on Financial Peace
University and find it as well but
fpu.com you can pick out which of these
so can how long has it been since you've
LED an FPU class it has been about 13
years wow Stacy and I uh LED three
classes in Atlanta and our time there
and I want to point out if you sign up
for my class I've got an evening slot so
U.S coasters and stuff I'm going to be
wearing in honor of Dave Ramsey my
leader my friend a mentor I'm going to
be wearing a leisure suit and also have
an A overhead projector we won't use it
but it'll be there as another War a
Leisure I know but I'm going to go a
decade earlier I said a bad series
I know but I'm gonna go it was not John
Travolta it was if the polyester variety
no it wasn't it was just bad it was just
bad it was just bad I've always wanted
to know what you mean by bad oh this is
just the way it looks cheap it was not
but it was not not polyester Leisure
soup but I'm gonna wear a laser shoot
just to make it fun so yeah I think
you're distancing I think you're not
going to sign up yeah I'm joking you
have to look at Ken there will be no
problems and no leisure suit oh wow but
it is an evening class it is and uh Jade
and I are both doing evening classes
because we know we got people all
different times a day but here's what's
cool go right now and see where the
personalities uh what the time slot is
because we're really making it available
to everybody from Aries times a little
bit of just behind the scenes stuff for
you guys they are a wee bit competitive
among themselves as to which one's going
to have the most sign up the fast yeah
fastest so if you want to support your
favorite Ramsay personality and you want
to go through one of their classes you
could jump in right now and give one of
them a lead so this is this is going to
be fun I think Eddie's going to win he
might but I can't compete with George
and Rachel I mean a jade Superstar
Financial you come to my class because
you're going to get some common sense
encouragement it's going to be fun I
just promise you that it's gonna be fun
oh he's already see I'm already working
already well see I'm working it is this
a competition it's just pitiful it is
accomplished oh it is oh I didn't know
all right well hey I'm going to get a
participation trophy yeah hey watch out
competition with you people all right
Bridger is with us in Salt Lake City hey
Bridger what's up
hey Dave how are you doing better than I
deserve how can we help
so I am
a senior in high school I'm just about
to graduate and I'm starting to think
about college you know where I'm going
to live what car I'm going to buy
um but I'm thinking about going into
Aviation and I don't want to go in debt
with flight school because it's super
expensive
what is the best route you think I can
go with that join the Air Force
through ROTC or the academy join the Air
Force and become a pilot
I was thinking about that because I I'm
kind of interested in you know F-16 and
being a fighter pilot you fly one of
those they'll let you fly the commercial
stuff later I promise
do you think because I know like
um
flying commercial in order to make good
money you need to be with that company
for a bazillion hours and you have to
pay for all those hours as a civilian
it's very expensive to get into this
world that you want to get into yeah
you're looking at right now average cost
about 96 000 with no previous experience
75 000 when starting with a certificate
and so I think Dave's right the easiest
most cost effective way if you've got
the chops and you've got to figure out
if you got the chops I'd start talking
to the Air Force you know you could also
be a Navy pilot so you got two options
and don't let them suck you into doing
something at the Air Force that's not
about being a pilot that's the reason
you're going over there is to be a pilot
so if they're not going to do that then
don't sign up with them
I'm not I'm not you know I don't I don't
want the recruiter to get to sidestep
you here and give you the old uh Olay
you know and so I don't want to do that
but I do want you to go over and talk to
them about what it's like to serve your
country for four years and come out with
the pilots with all the hours you need
to go commercial I mean it's uh that
will be awesome for you and um much
better than spending a hundred bucks a
hundred thousand dollars
uh and honestly the
uh
it's
it is a very romantic field to look at
from the outside looking in yes and yet
we work with a lot of commercial pilots
and Pilots with private planes as well
and private jets and so forth and um
it it you spend almost all your time not
flying it's true they'll tell you that I
think the best part is take off and
Landing so yeah and it's just that you
don't get to do you know and and it it
does it does not it turns into you know
you're a bus driver that's right you're
driving buses yeah they have wings and
an example here for this young man is is
also look at things like a helicopter
pilot you know in the Coast Guard same
deal but then you move out what about
you know a flying helicopters in medical
emergencies if your desire is to be in
the air and doing something that is
active and exciting to Dave's point you
got to look at all angles and the advice
again for this young man and all young
people thinking about something like
this hang out with some Pilots you know
someone who knows a pilot to your point
and have a conversation get an idea of
what's really involved yeah and I'm not
talking about a pilot that runs a um uh
uh yeah flight school flight flight
school yeah yeah that's not who we're
talking about that's correct he's trying
to make a sale but I'm talking about a
pilot who's done this for a long time
who's currently in the mess that is
commercial airlines oh my Lord what a
mess Steve's with us in San Antonio hi
Steve welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave how's it going better than I
deserve how can I help
yeah so a little bit about me I'm 23 uh
turning 24 next month God willing and
also I'm one year post graduation I have
5K saved up I earn a little less than
50k a year and I have the opportunity to
buy a house
um recently my cousin is moving out of
the city and he approached me and he
said hey
um 155 at the high and it would be
around 1300 a month
so I'm just wondering to see did you
tell me you had did you tell me you had
debt
I do I have 23k in student loans no you
don't need to buy a house
you're broke
man broke people shouldn't buy houses
it's not gonna be good for you it's not
a blessing real estate is not a blessing
it is not a good idea to buy real estate
when you're broke
that's why they call them brokers
your broker and broker and broker you're
gonna be broker no you're 23 you make 50
000 you need to clean up your debt mesh
you need to pile up some cash after your
debt mess is gone and you get on a tight
budget pay cash for everything and then
talk about buying a home when you're 25
and you've gotten this mess cleaned up
and you have a big old pile of cash no I
wouldn't do that I think it's a disaster
looking for a place to happen man please
please Steve please don't buy I mean by
Sean already well you know whatever it
is Steve please don't do it no no just
because your cousin has a house for sale
doesn't mean you need to buy a house
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
ha
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
there
their wash and guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
on the debt free stage Randy and
Jennifer are with us hey guys how are
you Hi how are you Ken thank you for
having us love the t-shirt I survived
Dave Ramsey and it's not in the budget
these are great t-shirts very well done
very well done where do you guys live
Tampa Florida cool and how much debt
have you paid off a hundred and twenty
two thousand dollars how long did this
take 26 months good for you wow and your
range of income during that two years
when we started 130
000 and we now about 160 000. good for
you what do you guys do for a living I'm
a nurse manager I work in the same house
Hospital distribution Tech ah very cool
all right what kind of debt was the 122
000. a little bit of everything we were
normal we had about 60 000 was of
student loans and parent loans
um about ten thousand dollars was credit
card and the rest was two vehicles ah
okay yeah you were normal yeah how long
you all been married 14 years okay and
you look up at the 12-year Mark or 11
year mark and say this sucks yes what
happened how did you connect with this
Ramsay thing well uh when the pandemic
started uh we obviously had to continue
working so it was driving to work there
was nobody on the roads it feels
wonderful that floor was good no traffic
yeah
um but it was kind of lonely and then
November 2020 I turned 50.
so retirement was kind of really really
close closer than ice ever felt the old
5-0 wake-up call yes and um so I started
kind of doing everything trying to save
money invest pay off debt felt a little
bit scattered so one day my son said Mom
you should listen to a podcast by Dave
Ramsey and I said what's a podcast and
here's Dave Ramsey so he had to download
the podcast app on my phone and then I
found your podcast 10 minutes I was
hooked
um and ironically one of the first month
of listening Ken and you had a show and
there was a veteran who called in and
you had made the statement that if you
put a dolled and Veteran on this they'll
just do it and I myself and a veteran
and when I heard that I said game on and
it feels pretty full circle now that I
come here to do my dad free screaming
Ken's here with you hello that's why so
Randy your wife is learning these
newfangled things and they called
podcasts and listening to a crazy man
and she comes home and says uh we're
getting ready what'd you say uh she told
me about this and I was like well first
thing my thought was Dave who yeah for
real but after she explained it and uh
all the details I was like well I'm all
in let's let's go for it wow and and
here we are that doesn't sound like such
a struggle that you need a t-shirt that
says I survived Dave Ramsey yeah I gotta
know more is that just a fun slogan or
was it really tough yeah it was really
tough I'm always so tough just that I
mean in order to do this program you
have to have communication I mean it's
so easy to just to like I said spend and
forget about it and spend and forget
about it and
before you know it you're you're
knee-deep and you know what so yeah yeah
well I mean and you've just been kind of
shuffling along and everything just
keeps getting bigger the debt does
exactly it doesn't go away you just add
to it a little bit every year and then
you look up and go we got 122 000 there
not even counting the house
yeah wow how intense was it I mean when
you went all in I and by the way what
tell us our audience what service what
branch of service you served in Air
Force Air Force thank you very much for
that so what was so intense I mean
what'd you guys do right out of the gate
because this is a lot of debt and a
little bit of time we followed
everything to the T I mean no eating out
never stepped foot in a restaurant
coffee shop nothing we literally got up
went to work came home that is it
um everything was budgeted down to the
dollar we love your every dollar app
um never use the budget in my entire
life that app is amazing I actually have
a panic attack now if it gets too close
to the start of the next month that I
don't have my budget made wow I love
this so
yeah so lots of discipline and also lots
of uh monthly budget meetings too that
helped dialed it in she really helped a
lot with that because we're like this is
how much we need this is how much we're
so that helped tremendously
so how much extra did you work
um well I'm salary so I couldn't do a
ton but there was a period of time I did
do some door dashing so here's the 50
year old woman door dashing food to 20
year olds
um while listening to a podcast while
listening to Dave Ramsey
and then Randy had a pretty
labor-intensive job for a period of time
that really uh brought some income in so
it was tough he was on afternoons I was
on days
okay wow well good job you guys good job
what do you tell people the key now to
getting out of debt is but just
communication like I said you have to be
to you you have to be on the same page
you just can't have one person dragging
the other person through this process
it's not going to work you know so you
guys really
um I mean you were very unified 100 yes
in this approach oh yes it's very
difficult to do if you're not especially
the amount of money you paid off in this
did you sell anything big nothing big we
didn't really have much you just paid
off the cars and kept them paid we still
stayed in the principles yeah that you
recommend so we figure we're just gonna
pay them off and now keep them forever
good good very good way to go how's it
feel to be free
it's amazing and we were very it's very
humbling to come up here to kind of put
your stupidity out here but the
debt-free screams definitely were a
motivator for us and kept us going
especially
in like Midway and you see these
mountains of debt and just hearing other
people's stories really helped us like
don't give up don't quit it's a
motivation so it's once you're to the
end I mean it is so worth it and now we
just did a quick trip here to meet you
and come to Ramsey Solutions and now we
get to watch all of our money pile up in
the savings
what a different emotion that is very
that you had when you turned 50 and
started looking at the end of life now
it's a whole different view yes yes it
is it is very cool very cool well
congratulations we're very proud of
y'all thank you very much extremely well
done excellent excellent story too and
uh no you didn't do anything that you
should be embarrassed about standing on
this stage you should you did a lot of
things you should be proud about and so
uh and most everybody in America has a
bunch of stupid debt and you guys decide
to do something about it which is pretty
impressive pretty impressive we've got
the live and give box for you that
includes the baby steps Millionaire's
book on latest number one best seller on
how to be a millionaire and that's where
you're going next for sure The Total
Money Makeover book that 10 million
people now have used and you've used the
principles from it for sure and uh
Financial Peace University membership
all of that you can either use it or
give it away it's so the live and give
box it's all for you guys and we sell
those of course in the bookstore as well
so thank you thank you so much for being
up here and uh you brought uh one of
your children with you yes my daughter
Madison's here with her boyfriend uh Eli
all right that's very good son Anthony's
at home okay dog sitting well somebody's
got to do it way to go Anthony all right
good stuff all right Randy and Jennifer
Tampa Florida 122
000 paid off in 26 months making 130 to
160. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
that's how that's done
it is interesting how many times
something happens in someone's life and
it
they have a baby they get married they
turn 50 they lose a job they get a new
job
and that is the there's this change that
gives them the wake-up call that's
exactly right yeah and they decide you
know what life where it is now is not
what we want it to be and we're going to
finally take the steps to live the life
we want and there's no regret with
people that pay off all their debt and
live with true Freedom Financial Peace
I've never had somebody do a debt free
screaming goes you know I'm so so bad at
I'm just sad that I did this that's
right I'm gonna go right back in debt I
never hear that this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining us America Ken
Coleman Ramsay personality it's my
co-host today thank you for joining us
Sean is with us in Orlando hey Sean how
are you
hey I'm doing just fine thanks Dave and
Ken for taking my call sure how can we
help
well my wife and I are in baby steps
seven and we're doing a monthly dollar
cost average into an s p index our time
frame is five years and my question is
do we continue the dollar cost average
for five years all the way through or do
we taper back into saving at a certain
point
why would you taper back into savings
well I've been
because I know that that the time frame
is shorter than five years you want to
save and not oh I see what you're saying
I see so what are you buying with us
a a new home upgrade our home that's fun
okay
um
no uh if you started if you started
tapering back to savings that would be
you're presupposing you're trying to
time the market and I wouldn't I would
just play it all the way through and
unless you see some
kind of serious Dark Cloud on the
horizon that scares you and then I would
just move it all to cash at the end of
The Five-Year period okay because you
know how much money are you going to
have in there after five years
probably about 100 125. okay and so if
it loses ten percent it's twelve
thousand dollars it does not keep you
from doing the deal
sure okay and that's that'd be the most
you would ever see I mean very very few
times in history do you see the market
lose more than 10 percent in the
12-month period of time very very few
times and so that's a that's an amount
of money you can absorb and it doesn't
keep you from doing the deal so I'm
gonna ride it all the way in and unless
I see some big huge
not just news not just stuff on the news
but I'm just really really really uh
concerned about uh the presidential
Administration or something like that
that's going to screw this thing up I'm
going to probably just sit there until I
buy and just take it out of the S P 500
and buy as a matter of fact the truth is
that's what I do I don't worry that much
about dollar cost averaging but I use an
S P 500 I throw excess cash in an S P
500 weighing over and above all my other
investing okay this is just excess cash
until it gets enough in there to buy a
piece of Real Estate
and whether that's a year two years five
years
seven years whatever it is I just keep
throwing it in there and then when I'm
ready I just take enough out of that s p
and buy that piece of real estate then
and in a sense that's what you're doing
and I do that all the time for
investment real estate
um and so right now I've got a pretty
good stash sitting in s p and the
Market's down and so I I'm gonna do
really good when the market rebounds so
it's going to be an excellent time next
you know next 12 months or so to pull
that out and buy some real estate except
that the real estate will probably have
gone up but um depending on what I'm
buying but anyway all that so to say
yeah I'm just going to ride it straight
through I'm not going to try to back off
and you know play the game against the
odds of and being cash you'll lose more
than you'll make 90 times out of 100
screwing around with that so good
question though thanks for calling in
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Ken Coleman
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
Ethan is in Asheville North Carolina hi
Ethan how are you I'm doing good how are
you doing better than I deserve how can
I help you sir well me and my wife are
thinking about considering the debt
consolidation loan we don't have any
type of credit card debt
um that's just something early on we
decided we didn't want to get into
um but really all we have I guess as far
as debt or a couple vehicle loans
um and uh the other big part of that we
have is whenever we had got our house
they had under budgeted us on our whale
and so we had to borrow about ten
thousand dollars from a family member
and we have also purchased a storage
building from that family member as well
so we actually owe them right at
thirteen five for everything so we're
trying to figure out if it's best to do
a debt consolidation loan for all of
that or if it would be better just to
make payments to them as we can afford
it the only thing with family
is I've seen a lot of times where your
family money and it causes issues yeah
you should have thought of that before
you bought a stupid Barn from them
that's that's my biggest thing is just
trying to figure out if we should do a
debt consolidation loan or if that's
even a good idea consolidation loan do
it just puts it in one pile instead of
four piles
pretty much yeah doesn't change anything
well I know sometimes because we had
figured it up it was going to save about
400 a month
um no it's not
not unless you stay in debt longer
okay that might be because you didn't
change your interest rate by five
thousand dollars a year on the figures
you gave me
you'd have to change your interest rate
by 10 what kind of car loans have you
got a 19 car loan
no sir no I've got a 12 car loan and
they were going to match that at the
debt consolidation loan yeah which means
you got absolutely gain no ground so
where the 400 savings come from only one
way mathematical it could happen and
that's extend the length of the loan
okay yeah that's what it was I believe
yeah yeah why you won't be in that
longer
well just because it was going to save
us a little bit of money I guess no it
didn't it saves you money per month it
didn't save you money you're going to be
in debt longer and it's going to cost
you more money because you're going to
pay interest longer
now that completely makes sense yeah so
what's your household income
uh well I'm self-employed my wife is a
stay-at-home mother what do you make it
was off it was 70 000 last year okay you
guys roll up your sleeves don't go to
restaurants and don't go on vacation you
get this crap cleaned up what do you all
on these cars
well I've got I've got a truck payment
and it's 16 000. we've got a Honda CRV
payment is 5500 is what we owe left on
it then we've got a personal loan to
borrow
um for a vehicle we got when we got the
vehicle the transmission went out so we
had to also borrow for that and the
total of that person alone is 6 500.
yeah okay
driving an awfully nice truck for this
mess
um so yeah you got you know you got what
forty five thousand dollars including
all the family junk and you make 70 and
so it's going to take you two years of
living on beans and rice rice and beans
and you'll be done
right list these deaths smallest to
largest pay minimum payments on
everything but the little one attack the
little one like your freaking life
depends on it
okay and go get your life back and quit
borrowing money for the stupid stuff
yes sir it did not bring you Joy
right yeah so next time you need a truck
don't buy one
unless you have the money be like your
grandpa don't buy it unless you can
afford it yeah you know I'd like to see
them beyond what you said I'd like to
see them jump start this and if it's me
I'm I'm looking if I've got some equity
in that truck I'm selling it I'm working
extra hours we are in the best part-time
economy as it relates to jobs we've ever
seen Dave in the history of America he
can go make some money I jump start this
and you know let me ask you this can
cause you talk about the jobs part all
the time and from the very first day we
started teaching Financial Peace
University 30 years ago we've told
people get an extra job that's right and
it used to be we tell them to deliver
pizza yeah now everybody seems to be
delivering food yeah ubereats right
um
and I'm not against Uber Eats or
doordashing or any of that that's all
fine it's an easy thing to plug in and
plug out right you can log in log out
just keep rocking you can manage your
own hours I'm not convinced it is the
most profitable part-time job it's not
and what are they yeah so they are
you're looking for manual labor
positions And what I mean by manual
labor does it mean shoveling or using a
hammer but if they just need a body to
stock shelves in warehousing
manufacturing right now is really really
strong they're paying more than you can
make doing Uber Eats yes much more
because if you go work for a Walmart or
a Target or a big box store and you're
working off hours so he's got a
full-time job he's running his own
business how can I pick up 20 hours a
week this is Rule
16 18 to 20 an hour depending on where
you are depending on where you are so
you gotta look the point is don't just
assume I'm going to go drive here's the
thing I was talking to when we were in
Salt Lake City the other day I was
talking to a group and uh just standing
around at one of our events and one of
them was telling me
stinking babysitter
yes is getting 30 bucks an hour that's
true
for babies dog walking yes for the lady
was on here yesterday dinner that free
screen yes 30 minutes for 30 yes rich
people don't even walk their own dog
that's exactly right what is this that's
right I know they're scared of leaves
that's right you get your leaf blower
you can make money because rich people
are scared of leaves but I didn't know
they don't even walk their own dog
that's right but just look in your local
economy who's having a hard time hiring
people see what they're paying this
isn't about skill this is about gazelle
and so go fill a gap and make some
really good money yeah kick your money
up drop your expenses Down clean your
mess up you can't borrow your way out of
debt that's the moral of the story of
this call that con consolidation doesn't
work because you haven't fixed the
problem in your mirror
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Ken Coleman
Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose is my co-host today we invite
your calls about your life your money
your career your jobs your relationships
whatever it is we'll talk to you about
it right here as we do every day triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Alex is in Seattle hey Alex what's up
hey Dave and Ken so I made a kind of a
silly mistake when I was a little
younger back in you're the only one
I know right everyone else has it right
nobody makes mistakes silly mistakes
when they're young that never happens
okay so what'd you do man
so I bought a house
um I bought a house with a mortgage
um got really low interest rate however
instead of refinancing a few years later
I went to my folks and asked if they
would pay it off and I could just pay
them at zero percent I'm realizing that
was now very silly um now that I'm
following your program especially it's
affecting my relationship with them and
some of my other family members so I'm
trying to figure out what the best
decision is to kind of pull out of that
um and like maybe do something like
underwriting with like Churchill I
started talking to them about that the
concern is because I haven't had a like
a payment or a mortgage for so long now
that I'm not going to be able to do
underwriting so I'm trying to figure out
what the best way is to get a regular
mortgage again
okay Churchill Mortgage can help you do
manual underwriting that does not
require a credit score
right you have to have to establish that
you pay your utilities on time and you
can prove that you pay your parents
timely with simply your checking account
history can't you
yes okay that that's the conversation we
had so far yeah so you can prove you
paid the payments and you prove you pay
your light bill you prove you pay your
water bill you can prove your income
I assume what's your what's your income
uh 105. okay got a great income how old
are you
uh 27. what's the house worth
it's currently worth 600. and what do
you owe on it
uh 296.
okay so 50 mortgage should not be a
reach
correct it's not a big deal tons and
tons of equity
you've got a great income how long have
you been in this job
uh five years yeah stable good income
and you pay you can show that you paid
your parents Timely
right
yes I can it should be a no-brainer for
a manual underwriting and if the person
you're talking to a Churchill Mortgage
can't figure that out ask to speak to
their boss because Churchill Mortgage
specializes in this in manual
underwriting because we teach people to
do it all the time and we send them a
lot of business because they're a
sponsor for 25 years and they'll take
good care of you somebody there will for
sure
um so get on the phone with them and
they'll walk you through this we do it
all the time I mean it's not it's not
this is not a problem so what's the
strain with the other family members
what are they twerked about
uh I have a few family members that are
happy with you of course but I ignore
those
um the other one I didn't I didn't get a
mortgage with your parents why are they
not happy with you for having a mortgage
no unhappy with Dave Ramsey that but I
ignore them
Oh I thought you said your parents and
your other family members weren't happy
with you is putting a strain on your
relationships
oh sorry so
some of my uh I've had other family
members ask my parents for money
so I am feeling the stress of I was
permitted yes and they were permitted no
well that's not your fault
agreed but they're mad at you
no they don't know about it that's the
the bigger thing okay okay all right and
you is there a stress with your parents
there wasn't at first they always give
me advice however it feels like the
advice is now more the money talking
sometimes okay
yeah the borrower is slave to the lender
and um indeed you know and there's
people in every family that don't like
Dave Ramsey including Dave Ramsey's
family what say it's not so
so it's something I've come to live with
Ken yes you're doing you're doing well
you're doing well with it it's working
out for me yeah if you only piss off
half of America you can still make a
really good living
and help a whole lot of people and uh
you know what we end up with is
um you know people that didn't want to
be helped uh and that's that's the
problem I want to make sure people don't
miss this Dave because we've taught this
for a long long time but this is a a
family who the parents wanted to help
this young man out they did and even
though they wanted to it still changes
the dynamic what is it about this that
we that why we create this boundary why
we preach this boundary
well it is a spiritual law the borrower
is slave to the lender
and the Bible doesn't say except in
cases where it's your mother and father
right now it doesn't say that or
accepting cases where Everyone likes
everyone no it doesn't say that it says
100 of the time that you borrow money
you take the position spiritually
mathematically
relationally of slave now you might have
a very kind and gentle master
that is very classy
um when we went broke uh 30 plus years
ago Sharon's dad loaned us some money to
keep a car
and he's the kindest most saintly man
gentle quite the opposite of Sharon's
husband and
um you know and he he
um you know we worked our way through
got it paid off and he he never one time
made us feel uncomfortable by his
actions or his attitudes but I can tell
you sitting at Thanksgiving dinner felt
different yes until I got that cleared
that's good because it's in the air you
can't change it you can't fix it and did
it make me more uncomfortable than it
did Sharon because it was her dad yeah
yeah I did of course but it doesn't but
you know it doesn't matter it's a slave
master relationship you change it so
when you loan your friend money they are
no longer your friend
you can't keep that from happening
they're your friend as a secondary thing
their primary relationship is now slave
and master yeah and it changes the
dynamic it changes the spirit in the air
you can smell it when you walk into
Thanksgiving dinner you can submit you
can feel it and Mom and Dad in this case
are probably pretty cool people uh
they're just trying to help again but
now they feel the real need to help
that's right and now they've gone over
the helpline and gone into the
controlling line and now they're
starting to interfere that's correct and
uh they don't really have the right to
do that except that they are owed 300
296 000 which kind of changes the it
does changes your vocal cords just a
little bit when you say it out loud this
is 300 not 396 thousand dollars yeah and
you're going on vacation what right you
know it's just like you they may be uh
pressuring him on professional moves
yeah you know and and this is right
maturity that girl you're dating spends
a lot that's right you get real control
that's true I mean you can get all into
crap when you don't have the right to
but you changed the relationship so you
know the old joke is if you loan your
brother-in-law a hundred dollars and he
never speaks to you again was it worth
it in some cases yes that's what I mean
yeah you change the relationship that's
what's happening this is the Rams to
share
[Music]
thank you
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality is my
co-host today if you like this show we
appreciate you
we do not have a 300 million dollar
advertising budget and we don't have a
football stadium named after us like
something or somebody like that no
excuse me um but the uh yeah we're just
like in here scratching and clawing and
trying to help you folk and it's what
we've been doing for a long long time if
you want to help us uh if you would
share this show tell people where you're
listening to it you can share that by a
link if you're on a podcast or YouTube
or you can tell people where the radio
station or on TBN or wherever it is
you're you're watching or listening or
however let people know leave a
five-star review please
everybody that does that's very helpful
you one star people you need to go
somewhere else
mama said if you had anything nice to
say don't say nothing at all so there
you go no thank you and of course you
can subscribe and follow and all those
appropriate things all those things help
this show move right to the front we are
now in the top 11 I think it is podcasts
in the world
of any category
and that's because of you guys thank you
thank you thank you we've had over a
billion
views on YouTube Because of You Folks
thank you thank you thank you and hey we
recently announced that smart conference
weekend is going to be in Chicago
Illinois this fall September 15th and
16th Friday night all day Saturday and
we hear over and over again from people
that the smart conference is the event
that lights a fire under their butts to
take control of their whole lives their
relationships their mental health their
anxiety their money their career their
job it's our biggest event of the Year
all the Ramsey personalities are
speaking on all the different subjects
of your life and you will leave smart
that's what we do and so with VIP
tickets you're gonna have a chance to
meet the Ramsay personalities Rachel
Cruz Dr John deloney George Campbell
Jade warshaw Ken Coleman me and you're
going to get amazing seats in a cool
swag with a platinum package if you're
on like baby step seven that includes a
first class dinner with me and all the
personalities after the event is over on
Saturday evening wow we're going to go
to a nice place there's only 60 of those
those will be a small dinner for just a
few of us we're going to have some fun
together we're gonna laugh and answer
questions to sign books and all that at
that so that's the Platinum the VIP is
very limited uh the Platinum is
extremely limited like I said the
general admission ticket started just 79
so we'd love to have you guys in Chicago
in September
ramseysolutions.com events uh did you
know that you were going to dinner with
some folks candidates I knew that I
didn't know how many but I like the uh
it's always fun to meet those fine folks
first time we've done that format I know
we have uh breakfasts and lunches at
this last smart conference here but this
is going to be fun yeah it won't be
chicken nuggets there either this Dave
likes the good food so it's gonna be
it's gonna be nice not why I just yeah
spoiled is what it is
I mean live like no one else later you
live and eat like no one there oh see I
like that that's good Kevin's with us
Kevin is in Corpus Christi Hey Kevin
what's up not much thanks for taking my
call Dave sure man how can we help uh I
am retired
um I was lucky enough to leave uh ATT
with a 401k and a retirement both I live
off the retirement and Social Security
after taxes I met about 4 500 a month
which is fine for me because everything
is paid for
uh my house was paid for my Ranch is
paid for everything's debt free
um
I'm over 70 years old
so in about a year and a half two years
I'm gonna have to start taking uh
cuts from my 401k automatic payouts the
government makes you yeah required
minimum distribution yeah right I don't
use that money it just sits there it was
making money under the Trump
Administration it's got to lose his
money right now yeah anyway uh I don't
really know what to do with that money
because I don't need it but I want my my
gut feeling is to invest it in Gold no
no no no no no no no we don't put
anything in Gold no if you don't need it
and You're Gonna Let You Wanna let it
sit somewhere let it sit in a good
mutual fund that's fine
that would do better than gold oh
absolutely I I I I own some gold
cufflinks and that's the only gold I've
got
okay I I just don't want to do anything
risky at this point that risky is gold
the gold is much more gold is much more
volatile if you look at the price of
gold on a chart it's way up and way down
much more than the stock market is a lot
riskier and it does not yield the net
return the average annual rate of return
on gold sucks
really yeah that's awful yeah I don't
know that much about it I've just heard
that goal was a good investment so yeah
usually from people that don't have any
money
that that 401k will just be part of my
daughter's inheritance that's cool
that's cool you're gonna pull that money
out of the 401K that we're talking about
because you're required to and I would
just be moving it into good
good mutual funds in in the process uh I
think I I'm gonna ask a question on
behalf of maybe new listeners maybe
somebody's never heard you talk about
this why are you so emphatic about gold
and well we know why it's up and down
why is it so up and down because the way
it's sold is well if the dollar gets
hurt you need gold I mean that's the
fear message that's behind this why is
gold so volatile
gold is a commodity
okay it's a it's a it's a rock that is
yellow
okay
you have barrels of oil
you have
uh precious metals diamonds
Commodities corn commodity
and commodities are all traded one
hundred percent based on people's
perception of shortage
if the perception is that there's a no
shortages there's too much of it the
price goes down
so like the the old movie orange juice
Futures with Trading Places with Eddie
Murphy which was a mythological future
okay there weren't orange Futures but
um but it was fun for the movie's sake
but the all that is is you're you're
you're betting on and commodities are
all more volatile than Investments that
actually create Revenue so in investment
that creates revenue is a company that's
running that makes a profit Home Depot
makes a profit Microsoft makes a profit
and it's either a lot of profit or not
much profit Apple makes a profit a lot
of profit and so their stock goes up
based on the fact that they are creating
Revenue gold and corn and oil does not
create Revenue it only trades based on
scarcity and people's perception that
scarcity is greed and fear yeah and it's
like I'm afraid so I'm going to rush
towards it and if a whole bunch of
people Rush towards it it creates a
shortage and the price goes up but
that's the only thing that causes the
price go up the gold did not become more
valuable just more people were chasing
fewer bars
that's all it is Supply demand drives it
up and so anytime you're investing in a
commodity you are at the mercy of the
psychology of the marketplace
Everybody's scared or everybody's greedy
and they're chasing two things so that's
the only way price is established where
if you buy a piece of income producing
real estate price is established based
on the income it creates
not based on oh it's real estate you
know it's not oh it's a golden Rock okay
so the golden Rock has no magical
qualities
it's a rock
it's a golden Rock
diamonds don't have magical qualities
they're a little clear thing and they're
not necessarily a girl's best friend
that is a marketing slogan by people who
sell diamonds yes because diamonds do
not go up in value I've got quite a lot
of them hanging around my wife yes yes
and so um and and let me tell you how
much they've gone up while I've owned
them not right at all right so for
people that are so rate of return is
called marriage but there is no actual
investment return on the stupid things
they're a complete waste of freaking
money otherwise so give us uh 30 40
seconds on these headlines that people
are seeing and that's why we get this
call in Gold they're seeing all the
dollars in danger China's making moves
Russia it's in the headlines all the
time what should they do when they hear
these headlines about the dollar and
it's the danger in the dollar well the
number one you can't run to Gold there's
nothing magical about it okay number two
Brazil and China and Russia our large
land masses
but Russia and Brazil are not large
economies
their gross domestic put output is very
low Texas has a larger gross domestic
production than Brazil
Texas is a bigger economy than Brazil
so do you think that Brazil and any of
their little friends are going to snipe
the dollar not a chance they're going to
have to do business with the 800 pound
gorilla and we do business in dollars so
they're going to be at our Mercy still
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today on the debt-free stage in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions Sean and
Ashley are with us hey guys how are you
Dave welcome good to have you how much
where you guys live Virginia Beach oh
cool 757
all right right there and uh how much
debt you guys paid off 83 892 dollars
good for you and how long did that take
in uh 28 months good for you and your
range of income during that two and a
half years is 65 000 up to 130. whoa
doubled it doubled it what do you all do
for a living
um I'm a stay-at-home mom and I also do
hair on the side and I'm a construction
project manager all right how'd you
double your income in two and a half
years a few promotions uh and a good
side work gig okay nice all right what
was your best uh best Money Maker sod
gig as a general contractor uh working
out of town
um just doing a general contracting work
on the side or just various construction
projects okay so like build a deck for
somebody or whatever yeah there's good
money in that really good money yeah
good for you good for you well done what
kind of debt was the 84 000 everything
credit cards student loans cars you name
it y'all freaking normal yeah yeah
that's awful I'm sorry I'm glad you woke
up how long you've been married
yeah yep two years yeah so you started
this right before you got married
yeah we canceled a wedding and we used
that to pay
um some of our debt off
she's a trooper yeah oh the covered
thing yeah okay well yeah we're not
gonna get here we're gonna do it now so
let's just get the debt off okay all
right and then we get married and keep
going yep all right good for you way to
go what kind of debt was the 84 000 you
told me it's all the different things
what was the uh
wake-up call that you get connected to
Ramsey how did you find us well um our
story started a little bit before
we started
May of 2019 we were three weeks away
from having our son Lucas We
unexpectedly lost him oh I don't know
and we found ourselves in a church
Ascent church is where we go shout out
to Thomas and Helen Lane they follow
your principles and they started their
Church completely debt free wow so that
is when Sean had a friend give him the
Total Money Makeover book The Craddock
family Dave craddick I went through your
program did his uh debt-free scream
years ago and um he just gave us the
Total Money Makeover and We're Off to
the Races from there listen to the
podcast
so your heart was broken absolutely
definitely and you the worst possible
tragedy that you can think of yes and
you end up in church yep praise God
praise God yeah yeah and um well that's
a good place to heal a broken heart and
um
get plugged into families to start
teaching you how to do life and part of
that is money yes yes how to do life and
so read this book yes yeah and then you
go gang okay while we put everything
together and walk through this covered
stuff and get married and all the stuff
we got to do here now uh we're going to
work on the money thing way to go y'all
that's very cool thanks that's very cool
I'm so sorry for what you went through
though thank you thank you can't think
of anything harder wow I'm also struck
by
the fact that you decided to no it was
covered and a lot of people were
canceling Weddings But you need a choice
you didn't have a choice but you you
didn't just cancel it you said we're
moving we're moving the money
we could have rescheduled of course we
chose not to and um how much was that
how much money it paid off all of the
debt that I brought to our marriage um
so it was about fifteen thousand dollars
how did that feel dude and here's why
I'm asking this that's a big time move
and I think a lot of people wouldn't do
that then you could excuse that but what
was your head and your heart saying to
you were they fighting each other or
were you on the same you both were like
nope this is absolutely nothing really
was leading us to I I think to this
um
I don't really think it's worth one day
um the rest of our lives we have to
celebrate our marriage it's not just all
about that one specific day I feel you
got married you just didn't have the big
West right exactly yeah I think a lot of
it had to do with um our son he was
supposed to be in our wedding and he
wasn't there so just a multitude of
things led to the decision Sean also
sold his truck so we both sacrificed
during this talk about that though the
jump start to that when you do that much
not everybody can do that let's
acknowledge that but you made some
pretty big moves that knock a lot of
debt out quick what does that do for
your momentum what did it do for you
it's huge it was a huge momentum boost
and it just reaffirmed that we were on
the right path it gave us the the total
momentum that we needed to just stay on
the plan and you know Ashley came with a
great idea to build a debt thermometer
that we were just a visual way that we
could kind of see where we're at with
the debt journey and um just seeing the
massive chunks that selling the car did
and and uh and taking the the the money
that we have for the wedding and put it
towards the day it was it was huge
contractor sells his truck that's real
tell me about it so what was what the
trucks sell for oh uh 25 000 I think so
that's a 25 000 move fifteen thousand
dollar move and boom boom boom and here
we go game on yep yes and uh we make
decisions to live and we're in a good
church and we're walking through the the
grieving process and we're fighting and
scratching and clawing and working extra
and wow wow what a what a radical two
and a half years very very much so yes
yeah very wild good for y'all I'm proud
of you thank you you're Warriors you
have fought through you fought through
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
um
and
um you just have to keep going
um
yeah yeah and understanding that you
know we're here to be good stewards of
God's money and when you have that
mindset the uh the truck you have or the
vehicle you have it's a little less
important yeah it's not yours it's his
and you ask him is just smart yes and he
goes nope you go oh God I saw a stupid
truck yeah so you cry a little and then
you cheer when it leaves
oh my gosh well way to go y'all very
very proud of you congratulations thank
you we've got the uh live and give box
for you the baby steps millionaires
number one best-selling book because
that's your next step your next uh
chapter in your story The Total Money
Makeover book now you'll be able to give
it to some guy you run into some gal you
run into at the church that is needing
to get started you'll be that guy now we
also
um have been fortunate enough that we
just ended leading our First Financial
Peace class oh wow yeah so that was
really awesome thank you it's an honor
to lead it and boy you really get it
when you're leading it for sure that's
right now we've also got a financial
peace membership in this box for you and
you'll be able to give that to somebody
that's deserving now that your
coordinators and leading classes thank
you for doing that of course y'all are
fun very very cool good stuff all right
bring the kiddos up and let's introduce
them and hear their names and ages so
this is Vivian Vivian is six years old
this is Amelia Amelia's two and Zoe
she's five months old boy what a great
pick you guys are awesome very well done
all right Sean and Ashley Vivian Amelia
and Zoe Virginia Beach 84
000 paid off in 28 months and boy talk
about a life changed 65 000 to 130
income count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
[Applause]
love it wow
very well done
it's amazing that in the middle of such
heartache uh yeah and you step into
spiritual transformation you step into
life transformation you chip in and like
she said life's gonna happen you just
gotta keep going yeah I just think of
scripture and the imagery there of
beauty from ashes and out of
unbelievable pain of losing that little
little boy
they decide to jump start
by moving the money from the wedding
that he couldn't be in that's that's
incredible incredible Grace
um and and transformation it's really
powerful stuff and then to see look at
those little precious princesses up
there they have no idea what Mom and
Daddy have done for them yeah not yet
not yet they'll look back oh man old
lady back in all 23
changed our family tree they'll be
telling their grandbabies that this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
thanks for joining us America Ken
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today the question of the day is brought
to you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services spring is here and neighborly
can help keep your home and yard in top
shape with the Grounds Guys mosquito Joe
Molly Maid and more so spend your time
enjoying your home not working on it go
to neighborly.com and you can find
service pros near you April is National
financial literacy month all month long
teachers and students in classrooms
Across America are taking time to talk
about the importance of learning good
money skills so we get some questions
from students this month today's
question is from Catherine in South
Carolina she asked my parents are paying
for college I have a paid for car and I
have a six-month emergency fund I want
to start a Roth IRA but I don't really
understand it what is it and what's the
best way for me to start one as a junior
in high school
well that's Papa Dave on that one oh
okay well you have to have an earned
income to do an IRA of any kind
uh and so you have to have some kind of
income that you pay taxes on so you have
to file a tax return showing your income
and uh you can put a maximum of six
thousand uh or or your earned income so
if you make 1242 dollars working
um
a teenager job of some kind and you file
a tax return on it you can put twelve
hundred forty two dollars into a Roth
IRA
so
um
uh
uh I would not do that
unless your parents are in
unbelievably fabulous wealthy financial
situation
my parents are going to pay for my
college can mean a lot of things
it could mean these are broke people
hoping they can figure out how to do
this
that they're going to borrow the money
to do it uh that they're going to do
whatever uh they may mean that they've
got eight million dollars in mutual
funds so paying for your colleges not
even doesn't even break a sweat
if that's the case then you can do a
Roth IRA but if they're if there's any
question at all any probability at all
that they're not
one thousand percent easily going to do
this
not not want to do it but gonna do it
can do it have the money to do it then
you need to not do a Roth IRA and save
the money for college
in case the bottom falls out of your
parents world and the best of intentions
leaves you I had to take out student
loans because my parents said they were
gonna pay it my dad went broke in my
junior year because he was so far in
debt doing nothing down real estate but
you know could this happen yes this
could happen right this could definitely
happen in this world so I don't know
where your parents money is coming from
but you need to
before you commit to not saving this
money for college I would not put money
in a Roth IRA until I knew I had College
covered you need to be able to cover
College if they don't unless you're
they're just unbelievably wealthy I
would not do a Roth but if you do do a
Roth you can do up to your earned income
and up to what you do not can in our
case
um when our kids Rachel included
or teenagers we were in very very very
good Finance we were multi-millionaires
okay in Good Financial shape so we knew
College was covered we had no question
about that and all that stuff was done I
had extra money to put into something
and so every dollar that they made I
filed a tax return on each of the kids
paid the taxes so whatever they made
babysitting working at Ramsay selling
books off the back table at a seminar
which they did do uh whatever that
wherever they were working at the mall I
added it all up as much as I could
honestly say that they made file a tax
return on that and then put that much in
their Roth IRA
and 1230 was one on one year that's why
I remember that number
um and one of them was five thousand
dollars one year and one of them was no
I don't think any of them maxed it out
ever I don't think any of them may maybe
yeah Rachel might have made six thousand
dollars one year because she could go
make money she she was the a money maker
but uh you know so we maxed them out and
it didn't max them out but we put a
couple thousand five thousand four
thousand three two twelve hundred thirty
whatever it is and then and then it just
sat there didn't add anything to it in
college because they didn't really pay I
didn't do tax returns when they were in
college they came out of college though
they had a lot of money already in Roth
IRAs that's fantastic I mean it wasn't
hundreds of thousands but there was a
good real good start for the hand on
that account when they got married and
came out of college and took off they
had a real good leg up so you can do
that if you're up at baby step seven and
you've got all kinds of room yes but
should a teenager fund their own Roth
IRA Almost Never
a teenager should uh fund their college
before they're from the Roth area it's a
education as bad as we all are mad about
it being overpriced as bad as we are mad
at people taking degree getting degrees
and stupid butt stuff that they
shouldn't
go get a good degree from a good college
don't overpay for it and and something
that's actually usable in the
marketplace
don't get a degree in German polka
history
okay there's only one thing you can do
with that get a PhD and teach other
people people German polka history
there's no outlook for that so you know
if you're not doing that and you're
gonna invest money and go to a state
school and spend 30 40 50 000 bucks in
in tuition and go through and get a
four-year degree and something that's
usable you'll get a better rate of
return on that Thirty or forty thousand
fifty thousand dollars then you will put
in that same money into a mutual fund
education's still worth it it went done
right when done right that's right yeah
and where it applies to
something that you want to do with your
life yeah you know the question that we
put before parents and students is is it
the only way is it the best way is it
the only way to get qualified to do what
I want or is it the best way and if the
answer is no to either one of those
there are other ways and let's be clear
that's still education just because it's
not a four-year school you're still
going to have to go to school go to Tech
school that's right and do whatever I
mean I don't care what you're doing but
listen if you stop learning After High
School yeah you're going to struggle
with your income the rest of your life
that is correct no matter what you do
and if you stop learning after college
I I read three books in the last month
that were non-fiction I mean you have
you cannot stop learning you have to
read something you know turn off Tiger
King and go be a better person right oh
my gosh right and so take a class go to
a conference uh you know watch a live
stream do something that you learn
something today sit down with a
successful person that's 20 30 years
older than you and interview like like
it was a book report on their life sit
down with people who are way ahead of
you
Pedro's in Hartford Connecticut hey
Pedro how are you
how you doing Randy better than we
deserve what's up
yeah I'm dealing with a little strange
situation and I just want to get like
expected opinion to see how I should um
tackle this okay so it's okay yeah so
get straight into the question so the uh
our landlord is currently wanna charge
us for an electric bill Benedict got
fixed and I believe the price is like
around two thousand and five hundred I'm
sorry the electric bill
the cost of electricity into the
apartment
yeah so here's what happened so we were
able um so the previous landlord
um gave us the green light to use uh one
of my drivers that we purchased and we
install it in the basement
now he told us that this is like an
electrical problem that the the
somebody else is getting billed under
the electricity that we use it for the
dryer but he told us that he's going to
fix that
um
fast forward four years later
um we have a new landlord now uh she
told us that um the currency never got
fixed the electric currency never got
fixed and uh
you know we we messed up and not telling
her that we were using the um her um the
electricity to dry our clothes under her
under her bill which so she blamed us
basically but
um
you know we had a conversation
um the day before yesterday and I told
her like listen like we didn't know that
the currency that they got fixed you
know our previous landlord told us that
it was okay for us to wash the clothes
that he was trying to handle this but
apparently he never handled that
situation yeah is there anything written
in the lease about this in any way
you do have what
no that we we have this contact
information the previous landlord no no
no no no I'm not talking about that I
said is there anything in a in the
written lease about this at all
no there's not anything tell your
landlord um you you have moved out right
we're going to move out but she um no
I'm not paying twenty five hundred
dollars
it's not on you and this is a verbal
disagreement and she's gonna have a heck
of a Time collecting it
um it's right it's on her she's owned a
house she didn't know where the dadgum
current was going that's on her
um not on you so it's on both of you for
doing a stupid butt deal but and not
getting things written down and fixed
and watch how business is done but it's
going to be a hassle Dave here you can
find all of our shows with the Ramsay
Network app on your smartphone it's the
only place to listen to the entire back
catalog of episodes download the Ramsay
Network app in your favorite app store
today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Ken
Coleman Ramsay personality is my co-host
today he's the host of the Ramsey
Network Ken Coleman show where he talks
to folks about their job about their
career about how to make more money
every day how to get out of a toxic work
environment every day and we're here to
help you today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
thanks for joining us Ashley's going to
start this hour off in Salem Oregon hi
Ashley how are you
hi Dave
better than I deserve what's up
my husband and I own a plumbing business
and it is a debt-free business and at
this point we are trying to decide when
our business is ready to bring on an
apprentice or hire a journeyman to help
move our business forward and what kind
of business did you say it is
a plumbing plumbing okay so you're going
to hire someone into the junior position
and work them up work their skill level
up by starting as a tournament or
Apprentice
correct a Apprentice is about a
four-year program here in Oregon and
then a journey when Jerry Newman would
be someone who has completed the program
and how quickly do they actually start
producing work
in about two years is when no no no no
no no no no you're gonna put them to
work day one
yes yes how quickly before they actually
do some work that has value to your
company regardless of their status as
licensed or journeyman or Apprentice or
whatever
they're going to start putting pipes in
right now
right yes so I I would say depending on
how well they receive the information
you know within 90 days we're going to
know if we're going to be probably ready
to put them into the apprenticeship
program
um based on their performances okay
so I guess what I'm looking for is any
time that a business is hiring someone
we have to make more on the work that
they do than they cost us
if we don't we go out of business
and so when you hire someone for 18 an
hour they have to produce something that
creates more than eighteen dollars an
hour for you in savings or in Revenue
produced or something
something has to happen that that makes
you worth that and um as soon as they
start self-sustaining meaning they're
producing more savings or Revenue than
they cost
um then then you're it's no longer a
problem it's now it's now a blessing
mathematically to the business does that
make sense
yes that doesn't make sense and I've
watched within the apprenticeship
program as my husband did it and has he
trained others that were in the company
he was at you know in in that two years
when they start sending them off to do
jobs and then the journeyman's coming
and they're checking their work so their
actual Revenue has definitely increased
yeah but if your husband can do twice as
much work because he's got a sidekick
yes
you're making money on the kid day one
okay are you turning away work right now
because your husband can't get to it
we are turning away a little bit of work
um you know you're coming out of the
winter season so it slows down during
that time and then heading towards
Summers and we're gonna start picking up
even more
um if you can do more work with the kid
than without the kid are you starting to
pay for himself that's right okay that's
what I'm talking about this is not about
apprenticeship
this is not about Journeymen this is not
about licensing this is not about that
it's do they create more production than
they cost
and at that point they're free
okay but until then there are cost does
that make sense right
so if your husband because he's got a
sidekick can bring in an extra
sixty thousand dollars a year and you're
paying the kid 40 you're making money
day as soon as you start that process
regardless of his title
mm-hmm
is that logical
yes that does make sense and some of our
foundation in that is like do we need to
have X amount saved up before we hire
this person as well
um you need to have enough to until they
start making you more than they cost you
so if it's going to be 90 days before
they add any value then you need 90 days
worth of their income set aside as extra
returned earnings
okay if it's gonna be if it's gonna be
six months before they're valuable then
you need six months of their income set
aside
because they're basically a cash drain
until they're not
and that that's what you're figuring out
how much of a cash drain are they before
they become a cash blessing hey let me
ask you this I show you how hard a time
are y'all having finding these people
um so when we first started discussing
it we've had like two high schoolers
that were interested because my husband
had talked to
um some young young adults which she'd
like to be able to train kids kind of
coming out of high school early 20s good
um
and so we that it's an area that he is
passionate about getting into and
working with
um so I don't think it'll be terribly
hard to find
um but it could take a little bit to
find the right click because you know
not everyone wants to be out digging a
ditch in the rain yeah it's like hard
work and stuff yeah let me ask you let
me give you a little bit advice really
quick on that for your husband
um that's true but you got to find the
kids that do want to be working with
their hands having a lot of autonomy and
serving by fixing and if you can show
them what that path looks like in one
year two years three years and say look
if you come in and do that hard work now
I'm telling you it's gonna pay off big
time you've got to sell that and that's
on him that's on you all to get that kid
who wants to do the type of work but
hasn't been taught how to do hard work
by the repair let me tell you who's
never unemployed
a plumber that's a fact isn't that the
truth
we are always going to need a plumber
that's exactly right yeah always so I
mean there's I mean car detailer you
might not need you probably can do that
but you're going to be a plumber you're
going that's right the trades are always
going to pay off hey micro is coming to
town with me next week and we are going
to do with Ken Coleman Dr John deloney
Nicholas eberstadt and uh uh Pastor
Craig groschel and uh Michael Easter who
wrote the book Comfort crisis uh we're
all doing an event here at the Ramsey
Events Center called America's labor
crisis hiring in this current
environment is crazy the live stream is
free you can watch this if you're
running a small business we're going to
talk about hiring in this environment
we're going to talk about the labor
crisis we're going to talk about the 7.2
million males 2554 that are not even
looking for work
they're sitting in their mother's
basement
and in the great turn of irony playing
Call of Duty
so yeah we're going to talk about all
this and we're going to talk about how
you business folks like in Ashley's
situation what you could do like Ken
just gave her some good Insight what
you're looking for and how to hire in
this environment and at Ramsey Solutions
we're hiring right now uh other people
are firing we're still hiring and in 30
years we've never laid off a soul for
financial reasons we fired people the
misbehaved for our people that didn't
weren't any good at their business but
but we've never laid somebody off
because we had a financial strain and
we're hiring and believe me we're way
more than just a radio show around this
place there's almost 1100 of us in this
building so check out the open rolls
here at ramseysolutions.com
slash careers and your programmers out
there we don't work 80 hours we go home
at 5 30.
and we don't ask you oh and we don't
work from home we work for work we work
from work we have a building we all come
together we like each other yeah
ramseysolutions.com careers this is the
Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
can Coleman Ramsay personality is my
co-host today again next
Thursday evening May the 4th May the 4th
be with you right yes be easy to
remember uh micro and I will be hosting
five top thought leaders including Mr
Ken Coleman on the subject of work
careers work ethic education crisis
there's a labor crisis in America we
have four million people quitting a
month still
and we have seven we have about five
million jobs in deficit right now the
the more jobs than workers and we have
7.2 million males I won't call them men
that are 25 to 54 years old that are
sitting at home not even looking for
work they're not even in the
unemployment statistics
we don't know what they're doing except
when you survey them according to
Nicholas eberstadt one of the people
that'll be on with us on next Thursday
night uh they are spending somewhere
from five to seven hours a day on
screens which means they're either
watching pornography or they are playing
Call of Duty
so I don't know what they're doing but
apparently not producing anything yeah
so except trouble for all of us so there
you go and CBS News coming out with when
it comes to quiet quitters highly paid
men lead The Exodus Ken you've been
talking about this a lot on your show
the Ken Coleman show yeah so we've got
college educated men who are making good
money who are doing this quiet quitting
this phenomenon that just basically says
I'm only going to do the bare minimum
I'm not going to go above and beyond I'm
not going to plug into a team I'm only
going to do what is expected to show up
and show up and it's really troubling
collect a paycheck yeah and so what's
happening is you've got men and this
this speaks to a lot about what we talk
about here when you hear us use phrases
like work that matters every human being
Dave longs to make a contribution and
when you have a job or you feel like I'm
not really driven towards a goal I don't
have a missional purposeful connection
to the work or to the organization then
this is what happens and you've got a
lot of skillful men who are basically
stealing from organizations they are
just getting by they're making it
through to Friday afternoon to happy
hour and drinking their face off because
there's no meaning there's no drive and
so that's one part of this male problem
the other part is what you just were
touching on is the seven plus million
men that are not working they're 25 to
54 they're working able
okay that means they can work but
they're not and the reason is because
they've left the workforce because of
status the data from these economists
are showing us these men are not making
the money or they don't have the
professional status so think of a title
or a job that maybe they desired and the
money with it and so instead of getting
back up on the horse and getting after
it they've literally taking their toys
and they've gone home I remember when I
was a kid we played with a bunch of guys
in the neighborhood and it all you don't
have like maybe you're playing cops and
robbers or Cowboys and whatever and
you've got this whole thing played out
and then somebody gets mad and they go
home and it ruins the game and that's
exactly what is happening it is a
childish response I'm not getting what I
expected out of life and so I'm gonna go
home and here's the worst part that's
right and family members and friends are
supporting these men and the government
and the government that's right but they
can't completely you know live this way
if we've got family members and friends
who say you know what it's time for you
to grow up I understand you got your
feelings hurt I am understand that you
were done wrong in some cases but you
need to go be productive and so that's
the crisis we're dealing with where we
have more jobs available than people who
are actually looking for work
you know and there's a sadness that goes
with this yeah
um it's you get a little bit disgusted
with these people in a sense when you
start talking about them but then when
you really dig into who they are number
one
a whole bunch of those folks
uh
fauci told them they weren't essential
that's correct and the rest of the
culture stood up and said you're not
essential
how would you like to be told you're not
essential that's right it makes me
excited about going back yeah
and um I was actually having a
discussion with one of the top
politicians in the middle of all of that
here in Tennessee a discussion and
um telling him that we were opening back
up here at Ramsey before they were
comfortable with us doing that because
the data that we had so that we were
perfectly safe and turns out we were
right
um so we opened up and everybody Dave
Ramsey is trying to kill his employees
remember all that right oh yeah and so
uh which is kind of boxy moronic if I
kill off all my employees I'm not gonna
get the work done that's kind of dumb
it's been a lot of money getting these
employees I'm not going to kill them all
um maybe one or two but no I'm kidding I
mean we didn't kill anybody everybody
lived it's okay so uh you know and he
said he said well I thought y'all could
I thought you all were still at work and
I said what do you mean he goes well I
just assumed you all were essential and
I said well how do you know if you're
essential and he's this is a top
oh yeah a local leader yeah the the top
yeah and how do you know you're
essential and he goes I'm not sure I
think you just decided you are right
yeah that makes a lot of sense because I
mean nobody ever really got the
definition of essential but we did tell
an entire generation of
waiters and waitresses to go home
because you're not essential
we told an entire generation of hotel
maids to go home you're not essential we
told people that cut hair to go home
you're not essential and boy did some of
you get to looking ragged after that
um because apparently they were
essential but not essential to me that's
for people like you I remember you were
like you got a haircut because you
needed a haircut you started calling me
helmet it was it was hurt my feelings
did look like a helmet I know it was a
covet head you know something Dave
there's something else too for decades
and micro is going to be co-hosting with
Dave Dave and Mike are good friends I've
had the opportunity to interview Mike
multiple times for our events here and
Mike told us a story years ago of being
in his high school with his guidance
counselor and above his guidance
counselor's head on the wall was a
poster that was very popular and it
essentially said showed split screen if
you will on one side as a college grad
with a diploma and a dentine Ting smile
and he was happy and on the other side
was a guy in overalls with a wrench that
could kill a Clydesdale and he's got you
know dirt and grease all over him and
he's sad and that was the message that
was marketed to us and so to add to what
David said we're working people aren't
happy well you're
if you're in the trades that's correct
and nowadays a diesel mechanic and a
bulldozer operator make more than some
of you lawyers that's fact but let's
think about these five these seven
million men who've taken their ball and
they've gone home because we don't want
to just attack them because it is said
man here's what they've heard for
decades we have told people that if you
can't get a degree you're less than yeah
and so this has played into the
psychology that they wake up so now I I
can't do any jobs that are that I'm
proud of so my mommy can brag about when
she's at this whatever at the nail salon
what's your son do I go remember I can't
tell you I'm ashamed of it and my son's
a doctor he's 800 million dollars in
debt and he can't breathe and he hates
being a doctor but he's a doctor yeah
and my son's a garbage man he's worth
eight million dollar net worth but see
Society has told these men high
probability if you collect garbage
you're going to be a multi-millionaire
right it's a big big money making
machine they're about as they're about
as necessary as plumbers that's right
that's but see Dave we've told these men
they're losers and now they believe it
and women in these same things it's not
that's correct that's right and so the
data on this that eberstadt has will be
talking about on Thursday night by the
way you guys sign up for that free live
stream you go to ramsaysolutions.com you
can watch this it's going to be about a
two-hour presentation it's some pretty
heavy stuff yes there's a lot of
psychology involved there's a lot of uh
economics involved uh there's some moral
ethical questions that are involved and
uh micro and I are not afraid to attack
those I'm a little more Rough and Tumble
than he is Mike's a little more
sophisticated in how he approaches these
things and a little more gentle with the
touch yes
I'm gonna throw a spear through your
face I mean it's just we're going to fix
this crap so I mean this is just has to
happen it's unbelievable I can't stand
it it makes me so yeah it's just it's
not just a boomer thing because here's
the thing of the seven guys 17 guys at
home it's they're not doing well their
suicide rate is through the roof yes
anxiety anxiety numbers and medicated
the number of them that are medicated is
through the roof they're uh the
depression numbers oh the despair
statistics on these guys is absolutely
horrible we have done them no favors by
teaching them that it's okay not to work
there is great dignity in work there's
great agency in work getting a callus is
a sign of respecting yourself whether
the calluses on your brain because you
face some stress and had perseverance
and grit and walk through it or whether
the callus is on your hand because you
run a bulldozer all day and you actually
cause crap to happen there is great
dignity in work and we got to get back
to that we're going to talk about that
Thursday night at length don't miss it
go to ramsaysolutions.com watch the free
live stream
[Music]
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today reminding you America's labor
crisis with micro Ken Coleman Dr John
deloney and other thought leaders and
experts on America's labor situation
right now a lot a free live stream next
Thursday night May the 4th we want you
to join us it is a free thing you can
just sign up for you got to go to
ramsesolutions.com and we'll send you
the link and get you all set up there'll
be about a thousand folks here on site
at the Ramsey Event Center with Mike and
I and um we're going to be talking about
this it's going to be a healthy
conversation Mike and I have enjoyed
discussing this offline uh too much
because we're both a little bit into
this idea that work ethic matters that
the trades matter that
um
people are essential and that they are
their best versions of themselves when
they are actually working Thomas is with
us in Greenville South Carolina Hey
Thomas welcome to the Ramsay show
hey hey thanks for having me certainly
how can I help
so I work at a small manufacturing
company we got about 45 employees total
I've got a team of seven and
um I love some insight on how to help my
team see just a bigger picture of we're
all in the company trying to get a
single goal not our department versus
their Department
um and want to pitch in when we've got a
slow period let's go help another
department instead of having the you
know not my job syndrome I'm not going
over there wow what is the uh singular
Vision can you describe it how you would
tell those seven folks if I was sitting
there watching you talk about it
in a nutshell it's uh ship units ship
Breakers
um that's that's what we're trying to do
is we're we're a startup we've had about
three years going and and we're still
trying to just get in a rhythm of we
need to get product out the door that's
quality that's on time that meets
customer spec and that's our goal how
many times has this happened this
question you described where couple or
is it the whole team of seven that are
griping about pitching in and helping
another team
unified I've got one guy who's pretty
consistently uh just quietly like all
right I'm gonna go over here and do what
I can but uh most everybody is very
comfortable with
um this is my job and they're doing a
great job with their job
um just not wanting to step outside of
that real house
right but I mean is the one guy or all
seven don't want to help the other team
when it's slow and we need to pitch in
is it all seven or just the one guy
no one guy's doing a great job of
helping the other six oh the other six
yeah okay I'm staying in my world well
welcome to leadership
um what you got to figure out is what's
driving that bad attitude this is an
attitude
um it happens here at Ramsey Solutions
all the time where we all say hey we're
going to jump in and help and and and
it's it's about the big picture Mission
if this helps them it helps Ramsay if it
helps Ramsey it helps me it's it's we're
a part of a much bigger picture and and
so when someone's not bought into that
it is an attitude and you have to figure
out where is the attitude coming from is
it selfishness or is it that they don't
feel valued they don't feel like they're
bought into the big picture I think
that's where you got to start Dave to
dive into that a little bit do you have
control over hiring and firing them
uh yeah
so you could hire new people into the
position
okay yeah okay all right because you're
probably gonna fire at least one mm-hmm
because you got somebody behind the
scenes that's running an undercurrent on
you
and setting the tone faster that they're
they're shoveling the poop in faster and
you can shovel it out
and you don't know who that is yet
because right now you got a blanket six
you got one good guy six bad ones all
six of them aren't bad five of them are
followers one of them's the dog and he's
probably gonna get fired when you figure
out who he is
yeah probably the only way you're gonna
get this cleaned up
because this is a disease that's
contagious
it didn't just land in there randomly it
has spread
this attitude and so by the way winning
is also Contagious by the way
enthusiastic response to the outcome of
the whole organization is is contagious
too cold it's culture You're Building
inside the organization and so the way
we talk about around here is we often
say we
this is what we do we as a team guys we
as a team when there's a need over there
we're going to enthusiastically help if
you want to be a we
you're going to enthusiastically help
because that's what we do you may not
want to be a we you may opt out and if
you don't that you just let me know and
we'll work that out I'll help you get
your severance package together but we
are going to do this and because when we
help the whole place the whole place
makes more money and when the whole
place makes more money we all have
opportunity to be promoted we all have
opportunity to make more money because
the place is making more money when the
place is barely struggling to get this
ad gum product out the door because
we're standing over here with our
fingers in our ear then we are harming
ourselves because we're shaking up the
stability of the whole place
you know this money that gets paid in
payroll doesn't come from freaking Santa
Claus it comes from the customers saying
you did a good job profit is the
Applause your customers give you and so
when we need to get something done
around here it is for in our own
personal selfish best interest to make
this place run as good as it can run
because that gives us the most upside we
get nothing but downside by sitting on
our butts so we are going to be fired up
and wired up and we are going to take
the hill we're going to push the ball
over the line and score the freaking
touchdown that's what we are going to do
now it's up to you whether you want to
be a we or not I can't make you be a wee
and Thomas A lot of times when I'm doing
a leadership conference people will ask
me uh how I motivate people I don't
motivate people I hire motivated people
and I fire demotivated people
and when I get enough motivated people
in the room the whole room will freaking
explode with electricity and I can't
make that happen but I can make the
environment happen because you cannot
win the Kentucky Derby with a donkey
yeah yep you know who the dog is
you know who the problem child is
not not offhand because like I said
they're all they're they're great at
their job yeah when you take each one of
them off for coffee to the side and you
have this we discussion
watch your body language and watch the
eyes yeah okay I'll tell you the next
question do I hear a sigh yeah I'll tell
you another technique I'm being lectured
again oh no this will be the last one
because you ain't gonna be here yeah so
Thomas there's another way to do this
too I agree you need to do the
one-on-one but I'll tell you the
quickest way to figure it out is put
them all in the room together all seven
guys and say hey when we've had to jump
in before I've noticed that we don't
have the best attitude and I want to
know your all thoughts what are your
stressors why do you what do you see
this just ask some open-ended questions
about what you see and get their
feelings and watch who they look at but
I don't think I don't think your snake
will say a thing
they'll look at the snake though watch
they'll look at them yeah they'll give a
side eye yeah it might happen yeah good
I'm just saying that's one option but
Dave could I throw another scenario out
here real quick to Thomas
this is also a part of leadership it's
why we do it we do it on trade
leadership and I the fact that you said
that all seven of these guys are good
workers they're just not six of them
don't have a good attitude about being
team players there is a difference you
can be a good worker but not a good team
player and I just wonder if they are
good workers it implies to me that they
have good character so maybe you come
alongside of them and say this is a way
to grow in your life and and here's why
we do this this the the talk that Dave
just gave that whole we talk I think
you're gonna have to train some of them
if they've got good character and they
work hard it is plausible that they
could be a good team player but you're
gonna have to cast vision and show them
specifically like Dave was laying out
I'd rework that exactly how Dave said it
I'd say it that way because I think good
workers Dave imply good character and
some of these young men haven't been
taught
how to to be a team player you get
socialized by the people you hang out
with boom and if you're hanging out with
people say well the little man can't get
ahead
thank God it's Friday it's true oh God
it's Monday if that's who you hang out
with you're gonna sound just like them
in a month
so you need some new friends really if
Eeyore is their spirit animal they gotta
go we gotta move on to something else oh
it's bad it's just awful I don't know
how we're gonna make it
jeez I'm on this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture today Psalm 128 2 you
shall eat the fruit of the labor of your
hands you shall be blessed
and it shall be well with you
James Jordan the father of Michael
Jordan said if you work hard you will
get the things you want pretty simple
yeah I can't disagree with that one
can't disagree with the results from his
son either that's right
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today he wrote the book from
paycheck to purpose he is one of
America's leading experts on careers on
jobs on finding purpose in your work and
we are talking about all of that today
the phone number eight eight two five
five two two five Steve is with us in St
Louis hi Steve welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey thank you guys how are you
better than we deserve sir what's up
so I've got a question about a labor
crisis that's what you guys were talking
about and boy I can feel it labor crisis
is affecting me too I own an accounting
firm and we did an acquisition of
another accounting firm uh maybe about a
year ago and with that acquisition
brought over a couple employees these
employees are really good workers they
do great work the clients like them a
lot but they don't fit with the
long-term vision of the company uh they
they don't fit culturally they've
actually undermined me with some
processes even to some clients in a
couple situations
but with the labor shortage I'm having a
hard time uh you know trying to figure
out what to do here they're not good
long term but they're great short term
I'm afraid why are they not a culture
fit why can they not adapt to your
culture you bought their company yeah we
bought their company and they were a
great accounting firm for 30 years and
they did not change their processes one
bit in 30 years I mean why can these
people not adapt and fit into your place
why why is it impossible for them to do
that
I don't think they want to I think they
like the way they used to do it better
yeah but I don't think they understand
that it's getting ready to cost them
their job
I don't know if they understand that
either I don't either and that's a
leadership thing that's on you
okay what they don't like is change
based on how you described and
understand well they're accountants yeah
right but most humans don't like change
but I mean but you got to understand
that it's not that they don't want to
it's that they're scared the death of
the change now as Dave said if you lay
it out for them and go you have to
change I'm going to be patient I'm going
to show you how to change and then they
buck up well then they don't want to but
you don't know that they don't want to
change we do know that change is scary
for everybody and certainly for
accountants so here's how it would sound
if it was at my place
okay
would sit down in private not in front
of anybody else very calmly
and quietly no raised voices
no swearing no nothing like that and we
just say listen
when we brought you guys in I as your
leader made a mistake and I need to
apologize for that
the mistake I made was I did not
communicate to you how important it is
that you're loyal to this team and to me
how important it is that you fit in with
the culture even if you do a good job
you're going to have to do those things
in order to stay
and I sure hope we can work this out
because you really do good work and I
didn't do a good job on the front end of
telling you that doing good work is not
the only thing you have to do to be here
and I'm making up for that today because
I want to be very clear with you doing
good work is not enough to let you stay
here we're also going to have to be
loyal to me if you have a disagreement
with me you never undermine me with a
customer again or that'll be your last
day
because we don't do that here if you
have a disagreement with me that's fine
I could be wrong and you're welcome to
disagree with me but you're going to do
it with me in private not in front of a
customer that's embarrassing for you for
me and for the customer and we don't do
that period that's a real breach of
Ethics now number two we as accountants
are not a people who like change but
change is coming and we have to embrace
some of it we have to add new
technologies we have to embrace some of
it in order to stay up with the times
otherwise we will be bought by another
firm
that's what happened to your old firm
and it's not going to happen to us
because we're going to make the
adaptations and change as part of it and
we're all going to go through the pain
of that it's painful for me too I don't
like change either I'm a freaking
accountant but I know I have to do this
and you do too so embracing the change
embracing the new processes and being
loyal are part of doing a good job here
simply doing the task is not enough for
you to remain with us you may want to
opt out based on this conversation and
if you do I understand but you need to
understand real clearly how we're going
to go forward you and me and that's very
kind
nothing mean about that is it no not at
all I'm finding a hard time uh I think
it'd be hard for me to find good
replacements for them and so I feel like
I've got to put up with them longer than
I would like I'm not putting up with a
crap you're talking about for 30 seconds
yeah yeah if if you if you want to write
a whole series of emails to trashing the
leadership of Ramsey and think you're
going to be working here tomorrow
you're confused no way yeah yeah and if
you're going to run me down with a
customer I'm going to talk to you one
time about that and say you know you I
listen I make a mistake every day you
can talk to me about my mistakes you can
talk to me about he wouldn't have done
it that way but we're gonna do that
together in private we're never doing
that in front of a customer you are not
going to create problems for the
customer and stay here I mean it's a
very short term it feels like it'd be
hard to service the clients without it
yeah you'll be all right you'll be all
right you're going to have a bigger
problem cleaning up the mess with your
clients if these goobers are running you
down to your clients yep yep you're
digging a bigger hole every day they do
that then you're gonna dig by them not
being there
I'm amazed at how fast how unimportant
we all are and you realize that after
you're gone for two weeks and nobody
notices
yeah and we're all that way yeah I mean
if I went off the air tomorrow it'd be
about three people cry and two of them
would be in my family and the rest of
you would be going well what else we're
going to watch
yeah I'd miss you Dave I'd miss you a
lot well I appreciate that thank you
well I got four I got four people but
yeah yeah Steve you're also assuming
here Dave gave you terrific advice and
you're assuming that they're going to go
well no Steve I'm not gonna make these
slight systemic changes I'm out you're
assuming that they're gonna Gamble and
you feel like the Gamble's On You by
confronting them in a very professional
way that Dave laid out and I I I don't
think you should assume that
um and so it's I could still hear the
fear and I understand where that's
coming from I don't say that from a
place of judgment I'm trying to set you
free from it to say look uh if you make
it very clear to them that they've got
to stop doing this uh this this this
undermining because it's the resisting
change and they must accept the change
this is exactly what they must accept or
we're gonna have to agree to part ways
you got to lay that with them my friend
because if you stay in a place where
you're afraid of it they will smell that
on you and it will turn toxic people
like that if it's truly something where
they are just kind of a nasty spirit and
they sense fear on you they will take an
inch and an inch and an inch and an inch
in an inch and one day you'll just be
done with it and you've had it and we're
trying to save you from that let me just
tell you
I am amazed that when you kindly and
gently and very clearly tell folks
what's going on that almost all the time
they get right on board yep
very seldom do you have somebody that
bows up and says well that's it I'm out
of here yep I agree with that unless
they already were out of here and that
conversation just finished it you know
but if they're if they're 50 50 what I'm
talking about will turn them and they'll
get right on board because I don't think
these are bad people I think they've
just been allowed to get away with this
crap yeah I think they've placated me
before by saying yeah I can make that
change but then they don't make that
change yeah and we don't discuss we
don't talk about what you say you're
going to do we talk about what you do
yeah and doing things is what we're
gonna is what's going to be required and
so you know if I tell my wife I'm gonna
send her flowers it don't count
it only counts if I do it
right you know my intent doesn't matter
yeah it's the actual action and my guess
is in this case that their fear of
losing their job is greater than the
fear of change and then he walks
alongside him and said listen I know
this is painful I'm going to serve you
well I'm going to help you with it we're
going to help you get through this
change it's not going to be as bad as
you found and we can do this together if
you want to do it but I can't make you
do it uh the only thing I can make you
do is not be here and I don't want to do
that I think you're valuable I want you
to be on the team and you know and I
goofed up by not letting you know this
on the very first day I should have told
you this on the first day
about that but now we're going to fix it
so here we go game on
that puts this hour the Ramsey Show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]